there's a line
a very powerful a very
compelling
statement about
the intensity with which things can
change
there are
decades
where nothing happens
and there are weeks
when decades happen
and i'm speaking of
how a
love relationship
can profoundly alter the course of your
life
you may go through life
for years on end
alone
without connection
walking in the valley of the shadow of
death in a kind of loneliness
drab of sorts
and all of a sudden
you can go
from these decades where nothing
to
weeks when decades happen
love at first sight requires the very
sign of its suddenness wrote roland
barthes the curtain parts
and what had never been seen is devoured
by the eyes
it's distinct abrupt framed it is
already a memory and what i mean by this
is that these encounters
these collisions these juxtapositions
these transitions from decades where
nothing happens to weeks when decades
happen is
the best potential rendering the closest
approximation in language that i think
exists to the ways in which
in which a love collision the ways in
which romantic passion can take hold of
us friends
it's it's it's
what is faulkner faulkner talks about
the writer's
futile yet noble efforts to fit the
world in a sentence because in these
moments there is a kind of psychedelic
telescoping of reality a reverse dolly
shot where you go
[Laughter]
and that's why roland barks says it's
distinct abrupt framed and already a
memory i mean it's a it's a literal
encounter with the mysterium tremendous
you know i mean love at first sight is
an encounter with the mysterium
tremendous it's a it's a time-stopping
experience you step off the people mover
carrying everyone else towards death and
you become like gods outside of time
co-mingling with one another again freed
from the trappings of time i mean again
in these moments everything changes
and crossing the threshold moving from
black and white to color from from
liquid to solid you know this this
obliteration of what once was to make
room for what now is well this
experience is simply amazing but i think
it's important to acknowledge its
telescoping qualities its reverse dolly
shot
properties the the characteristics of of
a heightened qualitative intensity of
being that happens in these moments
romantic passion should obliterate it
should annihilate what once was to make
room for what now is and i guess and i
guess the reason i'm speaking of this is
because i'm standing i'm standing at a
i'm standing at a kind of at an
intersection i'm standing at a at a fork
in the road i'm standing
at a at a ravine of sorts and there's a
kind of a leap of faith that happens in
this moment there's a kind of leap that
says i am ready for this kind of
psychedelic telescoping i am ready for
for experiences that that that crack
open my heart and that that are the
instantiation of going from from decades
where nothing happens to weeks when
decades happen i'm ready for this kind
of joyous transformation for this moment
of ecstatic illumination to meet the
eyes and the mind and the heart of
another to to to to to to see myself
reflected in the far away look in their
eyes for a duchenne smile to to emblazon
itself upon me i'm ready to meet her and
i'm ready for it to have these
properties that um
that surprise and that overwhelm and
that overcome
and uh
and so yeah that's that's
that's
how it should feel friends these these
these you know when martin buber talks
about i it and i thou
encounters you know i it are the trivial
and the instrumental in the everyday how
you doing how you doing how you doing
and then i thou are an encounter with a
person's soul
i am ready for my soulmate soulmate or
no mate
so um
yeah i just wanted to say that i wanted
to share that and hopefully you can
relate
to uh
to what i speak of
thank you for listening there are
decades where nothing happens and
remember
there are weeks
when decades happen